wait we beat this desert way what the
hell what Wade I don't know man I'll
just calm down what did we find it aha
see you look we're right here okay all
right yeah we'll take it there's lava
here I already hate this I don't think
I'm not gonna rock it out oh god they
shoot things why do they shoot when do
they shoot they just shoot at random oh
we don't want to exit here right cuz
there's a button down there what but the
excess like right here but down there
there's a button down to the left with
an exclamation point you see the bottom
middle why would we want to go down
there to get that button why would we
care about a button thread this needle
here nope nope nope I'm just gonna be
the one that waits here by the exit I
don't actually
definitely exit wait seems to know why
wait why do you know how do you know
well it's got oh god last time we're
playing you were just like blindly going
irregardless of turn rhyme or reason
like wait wait please what you're gonna
kill me there's no it's fine all you
gotta do is pop yeah watch this Bob wow
you did it too wait wait wait wait I can
do it
[Laughter]
excuse me excuse me genius coming
through watch this like there's a way
out okay wait your turn wait your turn
[Laughter]
[ __ ] okay that's hard I think the secret
is you gotta go ha ha there's no reason
to hesitate just go I did it yes hey
dishes you want me to leave no no no no
no no no we got that bottom boy I don't
know you guys know there was a point all
right there had to be one there had to
be a point but I don't know what it was
wait is that it's not a thing you can
pull down by where I'm standing or is
that just a light it's just a light
don't light don't be like go back no no
right this time that's how we do it
that's how we do it there's a slammer
there is a danger I made that first try
you didn't even have to deal with the
Smasher I had to deal with the Smasher
wait I jumped on your head
could you talk mean necessarily all
right man oh no oh no a lot of spikes
[Laughter]
easily what are you talking about the
spike keys on the right we're Bob Zack
spikes over there [ __ ] and you gotta
jump over my head no not those spikes
the other the other ones mark you're so
laggy
yeah I'm really executing this perfectly
I don't know I don't know you're saying
we're like inside the spikes and all
kinds of [ __ ] oh and maybe that
thing floating and gasp every sword I'm
just playing this with you guys
why all right so mark how do you do that
part you got over it and I want to stay
here just to feel a little sense of
accomplishment for a minute god damn my
fault your fault nowhere shitty
reasoning is that wait okay how the [ __ ]
did you actually liked it why did I do
that I won't do that yes
when you're on that wall you gotta you
gotta let go without jumping because you
deserve it with what you do is you wait
mark please okay I wait til I'm not
gonna jump on you I'm better than that
oh [ __ ] it's a very narrow it's really
easy just run and then dive at the end
you don't have to trigger it like that
it's fine everything's fine everything
so I don't get me what are you do you're
like a gorilla just slamming buttons on
your kind of gorilla screams goddamn
[ __ ] it's not that bad you just let go
and then jump at the bottom you just let
go and jump no you have to - no no no
you just let go from the wall and jump
but you don't quickly after yet there's
no dashing oh [ __ ] okay
wait this part that I'm getting - maybe
I pushed a button what did it do
shortcut I did it for you guys
well you haven't even tried it what are
you what do you complete Oh what are you
complaining about
no one would touch you God [ __ ] that
wasn't even on purpose I mean now I get
to go to the shore cut my trap wait here
conveyer and hope you're the one who
complains about all the anarchy no I'm
not complaining about anarchy I'm
complaining outweighed which I might be
the same thing but I haven't decided
there we go
I'm chaotic no [ __ ] I'm bad
are you just push right off the wall and
then join that's it wait you [ __ ]
[ __ ] made it ok [ __ ] Oh baby
so the exits to the left so you just
[ __ ] out here you guys want to keep
trying no no I don't wait I'm really
don't I don't have an opinion on this
matter
alright well Stan she did it wait ok you
can finish now sammich at sad weight is
like the boulder in Indiana that's about
right Oh baby there's a level in the
original blade trap wait yeah respawn
down here Oh fire fire the fire
[ __ ] oh my god Oh God Canon's
what did I do where am i button wait
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay this is a coin slot but that we
don't have any coins yet unless there
was a coin already you know I know you
hear about that stuff the coin is at the
coin at the top left
it's way their coin here telling three
people here is a hindrance right I think
one of you should leave okay I have an
idea you guys are idiots no you're
you're you're you're an idiot I almost
ha guys I picked out their way stupid
I've been up there okay all right I got
I know how do I know
wait why all right so now we just need
to go to the cornhole just let me do my
thing I know how to go to the hole -
you're not special I know how also
there's cannons [ __ ] wait there's
another way there's another way there's
a no the other way yeah there's another
true path I am the true all the true
mark how'd you get there okay where did
I go oh I don't know at the end we
didn't even go in the top right area no
no no distraction mechanism Mexican
channel whatever works well I am
confused hey we did it because there
were two exits from that one side like a
special oh yeah we unlocked a super easy
level oh dear oh cool I love lasers are
those guns you think nah I got this got
it I got it I don't know oh wait what's
happen
oh yeah I know it's happening I'm a
genius guys so smart
see you nerds what'd you do in your life
women wait open a shortcut for us I got
a respawn for me but open it
for you I don't know what to do
mark where's the respawn thing down
below right bluey hey Bob I don't get
past this you have to jump up on the
wall hello and then double jump and then
double jump and then - I did it wait
it's clearly easy double jump you get a
second jump in the air what do you mean
how do you double jump do this I have no
idea there's not enough space to jump
cool jump wait no yeah so let me see
what's over here first whoops [ __ ] what
is your what is your button do mark
there's a move that it moves that moves
the elevator because you you hit the
laser that was very clearly right next
to you the the one right in front of you
that don't for the love of God don't
well at least we've done here it mark
there's a button up here yeah you didn't
stay on hey Mark you wanna uh oh my god
you wanna send me bud no one needs to be
sent wait wait I got this wait you don't
got anything no wait I'm not gonna let
you ruin this for us God [ __ ] wait you
go push the button that you push the
[ __ ] button I like how there's this
nice teaching you know with this laser
like there's a teaching moment of the
laser up in the beginning and then and
then wait just five minutes completely
how do we get past this you have to you
have to go out from under it when it's
over us I guess I honestly I think just
from this if we're gonna jump up wait
well alright I'll push the button that
was I believe you [ __ ] that up guys
there you go alright so I'm over here I
pushed it oh [ __ ] I can't get back okay
is it smarty pants you open your app
needs to respect wait can you push the
button damn it I'll go push the button
I'll get it guys don't worry mr. muscle
neck is gonna save all your butts
alright we have to all go at the same
time then right and I'll just be up here
oh yeah
nice nice guys all right so you that
buttons push so no one's no one triple
laser you got this way whatever you're
about to do you got it yeah I'm not sure
do you have to go to that all right
perfect
I was trying to something under us you
see it you see it I see it I see it but
I don't know how that helps us here so
I'll trigger it you go back wait what
you just hit up you just hit a laser did
I yeah [ __ ] all right I hit it well
better than that
wait is it lower did this get lower no
yeah oh the thing got lower oh I see I
see
is it an ani blast me who's gifting a
hundred subs what the [ __ ] and why are
they not to me
mark we all need we know you need the
money how the balls do we get out of
here I'm less worried about the subs
although that does concern me still wait
can we put the crystal in the top middle
no no we have it so I think we just
leave I don't know if you guys really
want to blow minds that cash the charity
or to me but charity would be better
charity like Wade yeah Wade have you
seen his hammer I'm gonna buy more ovens
guys marques enough I don't know man I
think we've done that before that can't
be right
maybe the lavas the exit yeah Baba's not
the exit guys I'm at this button again
and see everything different happens hey
that was pretty good that left-hand wall
you can't walk through the wall over
there right that way oh no I need night
rooms over there what happens wait what
happens if I push the top button if I
can [ __ ] just lowers this one thing I
think we just leave wait wait why did
you just disconnect leave you stupid
fool yep you didn't hit world
did you a dropout exits of Maine he
exited this session oh my god I'm in
charge now
we're on the world map now okay I got a
bad feeling that it didn't register us
as completing that level zero it's a
zero zero dead still crystal here no
there's no crystal okay we're good all
right don't exit to Maine
no yeah we all know that be a ridiculous
Reno yeah God me first
oops yeah I don't know I did quit
existing everywhere you're on the screen
do you not see it
I see me now few moments of peace down
here before you [ __ ] and ruin ah [ __ ] oh
thank god I don't know I don't know it's
not back it's it's gray it's [ __ ] bad
gray before wasn't knows gold for me now
it's great for me okay you good Oh like
[ __ ] wizards
well I died so I guess mutton not a very
good wizard I made it okay guys watch
what wait hang on what's up here I got a
little eyeball thing oh there's a little
eyeball up there do you see it yeah I do
see it did Wade die and worse wait I'm
alive why do you watch muck or do you
not hit the bass hit the bounce I hit it
so good oh my god what the how bouncy
these bouncers are oh not very okay
did you see that
no I didn't I stood on the ground next
to the balance fell oh [ __ ] you just
walked home
you just walked right that's all you do
you walk right not then you [ __ ]
genius
now time it the first saw is gonna be
around the top so you want to start
walking forward when that says if you
just walk right away that's easy
[ __ ] out got it you got it we believe
and this all right so from here I walk
to the row no one down when you go to
the next ledge down when that wonderful
first saw is at the top just walk right
[Laughter]
we went through god that's a joke we
can't tell right no not funny
wait I'm not the controller anymore we
need to restart the love okay you know
what I don't know how to make you in
head charge things so just shut up don't
know how Macon had you charged don't
know how [ __ ] any AXI [ __ ] go forward
you got it there's a cannon let me get
to the next one okay
[Laughter]
you lost your chance barely oh god oh
god oh god I felt that on my hair I
think I'm fine if I stand there's a
Ledge directly below you all you got to
do is drop on it there you go I'm gonna
stand am i fine am i fine random chance
would have had you in there by now we
have to go left and right in this video
in this level right you don't know that
Tigers no one has said swagger in six
years oh man I almost just ate those
bikes like a douche bag for me so
doesn't shoot me in the balls
I gotta get over there first it's a bit
of a road it's okay you know I'm just
timing it out for some reason I'm not
timing out my my - sorry - just properly
it's my turn next wait right it's my
turn now oh do you have to crouch here I
think yes you do I scientifically
determined that you have to crouch
[Laughter]
this is quickly too difficult for us
it's really easy this is nothing
compared to the hardest ones we've done
before so this should be a cakewalk
right
why is my - jump not working you you you
using me against me you don't have to -
jump man it's fine why would you go why
are you not dead
that's my question Oh Punk shoulda
waited for your turn oh oh oh and you
were gone what do you mean wait advisor
don't speak to me that this phone mister
oh I'm [ __ ] I can't my dad jump just
doesn't work anymore oh [ __ ] my dad shop
was working at the wrong time have to -
my just saying come on man yeah whatever
whatever you know I just want it to be
consistent and it's not Oh goodbye okay
I'm gonna make you guys here we go sweet
Bhutan alright okay alright here we go
yeah
oh that's not a sweet Bhutan no hey guys
hey it's not it's not sorry sorry sorry
your turn you can do it oh [ __ ] I got
this pretty sure mark is our only hope
come back down here and start over
are they joking with this alright
you have to jump up you have to use your
dash - no mark the - nice nice nice nice
nice Oh God
I can do this I can do [ __ ] I will
murder you wait your turn wait to do it
you touched me you're damn right I did
no why does it not work how many times I
had to coach you don't need to - that
one mom you know I'm just saying I want
it to be consistent all I want
oh that was bad boy oh that was a bad
boy how's it bad but we
okay I didn't make it on a normal jump
there Bob you know I wanna watch dashing
this ever look normal you're dropping
off you're dropping yeah well that's not
a swear I swear I swear I swear
[Laughter]
wait your turn go mark oh yeah oh [ __ ] I
didn't have to dad god this guy's just
just buff look you were honestly our
only actual hope I can do this I swear
to God I can do this I'm gonna wait you
tournament I am our only hope you heard
it straight from Bob new one holy [ __ ]
how'd you do that I don't know man I
don't know I don't ask you don't say did
you see that [ __ ] what your turn wait
for more I will I swear to God watch
this [ __ ] mark watch this that was good
man oh I can do this I can do this
[Laughter]
Wow
okay there's gonna be the one go yeah
[Music]
mark did you see that look at me I did
Oh God the only one who walks I can't
get out of here because you guys are
here
[Laughter]
why did you even do that oh god mark
you're wizard I know
ciao [ __ ] no one else has been here
before mark look at me yeah yeah don't
do it wait oh wait oh god okay no oh my
god mark what the [ __ ]
I swear I'm back here now you're right
okay alright what I gotta do is not fall
down what oh do I could you climb that
rope down no no you can't and I wouldn't
come back anyway I'm climb the rope
climb the rope that'll do it with it
would this make it I don't think that
would this make it the platform holding
the rope right no it's not platform
that's where I died last time oh it is
wait oh it wasn't before okay whatever
this bow god oh my god oh what the [ __ ]
mark I swear guys I swear you guys I
can't even get past this first [ __ ]
show what do you want an easy mode oh
[ __ ] no though I give up thanks I give
up no don't go I went between them wait
school ready you're trying to kill me
well I'm practicing my jumps you're
trying to kill me
I was absolutely trying to kill you Oh
pop burned me twice what I do here
you slide whoa okay I got I got a hop it
it's it's just a little ease the slide
better but yeah it's a little tight you
are trying you're trying no I'm trying
to make it you're not you you haven't
tried in it like [ __ ] you haven't you
guys haven't tried it in like minutes
I've been trying I'm not good I don't
know you want bob has tried Wade you
you're you're worse than the spikes you
you you're the ultimate obstacle in this
game to follow you around wait are you
actually trying to do it right now Jesus
what are you doing nothing
Tory we'd go for it I have a solution to
this problem Marco thank you
so you are the final boss of this game
[Laughter]
god damn it oh [ __ ] that's hard yeah you
worried the spikes there Dale have you
not been able to do this first maneuver
it's like you how have you gotten oh
wait you haven't gotten this far in the
game how many levels have you actually
completed wait wait how do I constantly
get roped into doing just duo's you and
me after the stream ends Bob's like out
of here you know I beat two of them my
your power gaming buddy is that all I am
to you oh my god it's all learning oh
I'm glad I took you with me wait am I
just you're like level up buddy I just
here to make you look like you're
stronger and better game so that while
you play with me after the stream no you
just what you want me here so you
couldn't feel like you're really good
compared to me that well yes goddamn it
wait you [ __ ] double with some what
are you doing wait what are you thank
you mark please God I do the thing if I
get through this it's just and you see
the other hell waiting I do see that
mats are good there's probably a seeker
with it right
fireball guys just [ __ ] there all
right guys I'm gonna get this I'm gonna
get this oh hey Chris don't make me
laugh okay what in the fresh hell oh my
place all right looks complicated you
just go all the way to the right you
slide down that wall then you over you
jump and slide oh that's true isn't it
you fall you jump you - you slide down
that wall
you fall jump - real easy man just like
that you know I don't think that's right
I have to judge it because I'm a good
coach doesn't mean I'm a player what I
have to do is I have to get to this wall
the overhang that's blocking the exit
there I have to touch that drop off of a
jump holy [ __ ] okay all right here we go
no I need to I need to jump off from the
very beginning [ __ ] I died that was I'm
here now so we're getting closer yeah
all right you got that I swear wait this
is why don't come back to Ohio this is
why forth it Wow mark your wizard your
wizard be a wizard be a wizard okay I've
got that down oh that's impossible
those are too fast how the [ __ ] hey guys
wait I found the exit no no wait wait
wait I did it I got I can do this I'm
honestly very close so just I I can do
this you guys need to believe in me if
you're not believing in me I'm never I'm
never gonna I appear I'm like Santa I
don't forget that for years man but
ever actually believed and yet you've
some health manage time mark let's party
[ __ ] with the stupid me in the leg
oh [ __ ] me in the leg - my leg needs
lovin oh touch my kneecap Oh God dang it
I need my knee please I might have the
solution it's not any easier my buttons
don't work
bark-bark bark-bark-bark yeah yeah yeah
uh-huh I'm having trouble wall jumping
I'm getting like a lot of lag spikes
when I'm doing a lot of inputs not that
I'm good at this but I feel like lag is
also impacting my ability to like do
stuff what I have to do I think is jump
- touch the very lip of that wall drop
immediately before the spike gets to me
and then pray that I make that last jump
oh oh [ __ ] my human jeez my god did you
just figure out something yeah I did
it's it's easier than I thought I don't
have flow I don't have to do the
craziness guys I need everybody to
believe in me believe in me harder I
believe for a price that's a little
little more than I was hoping
okay 15 you talked me into it alright
your tough negotiator 12 5 this is so
important come on come on I even [ __ ]
your uncle for an extra 10 bucks
uncle Somaly calm no jokes no jokes okay
no I'm serious time Wade
anymore no okay all right
no it's too fast it's so fast huh oh oh
sorry Bob
oh god please no oh oh I've never been
in here before Hey doing good Bob
ah [ __ ] well now I don't know how to do
this I'm gonna just stay out of the way
it's just it's just timing like it's
there's the thing I'm not very good at
it's not a complicated thing wait your
turn mark okay oh jesus ow No yeah it's
it's just a slow timing thing mark how's
it going is not mmm I wouldn't do
anything to you man calm down unless you
were sleeping right guys is that a
reference to something mark mark mark
mark he's our man if he can't pay me who
will do you need to do you need to slide
down the left wall and my lower so that
you have more time before the spikes no
you won't make the distance that's why I
tried the first time it's it's just
really I think it's just really up well
[ __ ] it's just a really precise gap it's
probably a very simple pattern it's just
like nailing the timing of it cuz it
looks intimidating I don't think it's
that bad I just don't know what it is in
and trial and error it's so far out it's
at the end of the level I can't trial
and [ __ ] you like stomped on me or
something I didn't I didn't - left booth
one stop right foot again I swear he's
just like a soundboard any he says just
some random quote from from a reference
like 15 years ago after this can we play
something I'm less bad at yeah like uno
or something there's no skill involved
and I'm just loose but I feel like it's
not my fault oh my god I can't do the
saws anymore oh god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh okay don't look
at me during all right now instead of
swearing I have some prepared responses
that I'm gonna be able to sound bored at
you so it'll be it'll be less negative
I'm gonna be a positive boy
from I did it hooray now on that's just
I'm glad we're playing this oh yeah it's
so fun you can kill me before you move
on you just do like a stop away to this
to move on I'm already beyond you come
back
I've ascended that yeah I know
I didn't mean to that guys will be back
but that's it that's all it takes
I can do it I can do it hey it's all it
takes oh god this is how you do it guys
I said this is the way I knew it simply
knows I knew it was more simple than I
thought it's not exactly what I told you
should do like the beginning and then
jump there you're like wait so I sound
like you don't want to get themselves in
the chat mark please my dear friend just
a little bit of porridge and you were
like oh I'm not gonna tell you anything
ever listen to you wait jumping your
soundboard
mark mark homie my main man you know of
all the things do you say I think homie
my main man is my favorite one of them
does that date me does it make me sound
old off oh god I didn't get the timing
of the fireball are you waiting it
I'm machine-learning right now yeah me
too but eventually I'll learn the tactic
that works for this so alright you know
what to do oh I know what to do
[Music]
alright guys were for through this level
good work we do that one again there was
a coin in a level we didn't guys oh my
god
world six no no no no bikes no guys why
are you wait stop this is how you always
are you're like you don't try the whole
level enjoy Oracle let's go come on it's
time to go get back on the horse
failures and what keeps you sound like
to you
yes of course it is guys do you actually
do just walk on to it and then what oh
man you really yeah those spikes sucks
your donkey dong I will always be too my
breasts are small and humble all right I
think marks right I think marks right I
think marks right I think marks right
I'm yeah that's enough for me
[Music]